i just want to take the time to say i'm
really sorry it's heartbreaking
and it's devastating it's
it's just it's just disappointing a
shocking finale capped off the most
controversial season of the bachelor
when
i think about the life i want to live
i think about living that life with you
and the truth is that i love you
[Music]
matt james gave the final rose to rachel
kirk connell but it was the beginning of
the end for this reality tv romance
take me to the specific moment when you
first were made aware
of these images rachel might not
understand
what it means to be black in america
rachel faced backlash shortly after the
season premiered
stemming from allegations of racist
behavior and pics that surfaced of her
attending an old south plantation themed
party
not a good look this was followed by
chris harrison stepping away from the
bachelor franchise after he defended
rachel
and her past actions as long as there's
good things being discussed
now months after the season completed
filming former nfl star
emanuel acho stepped in to replace
harrison as host of after the final rose
so you all are no longer together no
sorry to hear that where matt revealed
he and rachel have gone their separate
ways
what was that breakup conversation like
it was
as tough as you could imagine and it's
heartbreaking
the revelations about rachel and her
initial reaction to the backlash caused
matt to rethink
their relationship if you don't
understand
that something like that is problematic
in 2018
there's a lot of me that you won't
understand and it's it's it's
it's as simple as that rachel was
interviewed by herself
and alongside matt where she opened up
about the controversy
i'm not going to sit here and say that i
didn't know any better
because i could have easily asked myself
those questions
no i never took the time to make that
connection because if i would have taken
the time i easily could have
understood what was wrong with it
holding hands during a heartfelt
conversation
matt revealed what was going through his
mind as they were breaking up
the most disappointing thing for me
was having to explain to you
why what i saw was problematic and why i
was so upset
in an uncomfortable moment towards the
end emanuel said matt and rachel could
take a moment to embrace
but matt simply left everyone with this
i don't know if it'll ever not hurt
hearing those things